this is a production of Cornell
University
thanks Jim I appreciate it I wish I was
dressed like Jim right about now to be
honest with you so I can I can offer
pretty much uh unambiguous proof for
global warming When I Was An
undergraduate here back in the early 80s
I don't think in the four years I was
here it ever got this hot in the entire
four years I was here so uh it is it is
warm out there I guess I bought it from
North Carolina so today I'm going to
tell you about cytokine and signaling uh
mostly mostly unfortunately no ethylene
today Jim but uh we're going to talk
mostly about cytokine insignia
it wasn't yeah so just uh cytokinins
were discovered of course as most of you
probably know here uh from the
pioneering work of of uh folky skoog uh
and Carlos Miller working folkie's lab
and they discovered the the existence of
cytokine in the 1950s and their initial
Discovery was was that cytokinins in
concert with of course his other hormone
auction promoted cell division or
cytokinesis hence the name and they made
two seminal observations about cytokine
and one is that cytokine in in concert
with oxen could promote cell division
but also that the relative ratio of
these two hormones determine the uh
differentiation of organ or
organogenesis from undifferentiated
cultures so this is tobacco cultured
cells and you can see it relatively high
concentrations of cytokine shoot-like
organs form that eventually shoots would
form at relatively High auxin
concentration it's Roots would form and
then it intermediate or high
concentrations of both you'd get this
undifferentiated growth so cytokines
were discovered in the 19 50s
after that there was quite a bit of work
going now
all right so since they were discovered
uh uh quite a few roles were elucidated
for cytokine some of it was from from
exogenous application but a lot of it
was derived from an analysis of our
favorite model system arabidopsis much
of this was the result of uh loss of
function mutations that made made plants
insensitive to cytokinin and like pretty
much any of the phytohormones somebody
could show a slide just like this if you
worked for Ada or if you worked for
auction if you worked for GA you're
going to show a slide just like this
which basically highlights the
pleiotropy or the pleiotropic nature of
hormones that they basically do
or affect almost every Developmental and
growth process in plants and cytokine is
no exception uh and so they do things
like for example promote cell division
in the shoot apical meristem they
actually inhibit cell division down in
the root apical meristem they as she
send those they inhibit leaves in
essence they regulate oxalate Bud growth
and so on and so forth so they do many
many different things and so the
question that we addressed
uh quite quite some time ago is how is
it that plants perceive cytokine and
transduce the signal and then a offshoot
of that question is how does one simple
signaling molecule do so many different
things
so in different tissue that has
completely different roles
okay so to get at this question of how
plants perceive cytokine in a couple a
couple years ago actually probably a
couple decades ago now uh two
independent lines of Investigation led
to really the elucidation of the
cytokine and signaling pathway one was
done by a very talented research itatsu
kakimoto in Japan and he was screening
for things that allowed a rapidopsis in
this case to form shoots in the absence
of exogenous cytokin so normally in a
wild type plant shown on the left if you
don't give any as I told you before if
you don't get any cytokine and you give
oxygen you get lots of root growth and
then if you give auxin plus cytokine and
you do shoot formation in culture
he found a line that in the absence of
exogenous cytokine informed shoots they
called it ck1 for cytokine insensitive
and as you'll see in a moment it was a
result of the overexpression of a gene
called the histidine kindness so it
turns out that the gene is over
expressing here ck1 almost certainly
does not play a role in cytokine and
signaling but but paralogs of CK I want
to do
in parallel we were trying to find genes
that were rapidly and specifically
induced by cytokinin and we used a
technique that probably nobody this in
this audience knows called differential
display which doesn't matter what it is
but it was a way to identify genes that
were induced in response to a particular
hormone now back when we first started
working on cytokinin the cytokine
responsive genes were induced with with
treatment of cytokine in about six or
seven hours a long long term treatment
we wanted to find a Primary Response
Gene the first genes that are targeted
after you give exogenous cytokinin and
we identified a gene that is now called
ar5 that was rapidly and uh at least
rapidly the rapidity was specific for
cytokine and for the young
undergraduates and their graduate
students that's called the northern
block nobody ever does Northern blocks
anymore in fact everything I did as a
graduate student postdoc isn't done
anymore but anyway uh so we found this
Gene called ar5 and these two lines of
Investigations converged in the same
kind of signaling pathway so called two
component signaling pathway
these are ubiquitous and bacterial cells
so you know that animals and and and
other eukaryotes and plants have things
like serine threatening kinases and and
animals anyway tyrosine kinases
in general bacteria don't have such
elements they have these two component
elements to perceive and sense the world
around them and as the name implies
they're comprised of two elements a
receptor called the sensor histidine
kinase and an output uh signaling
element called the response regulator
and so the basic idea is that the input
domain binds some signal whatever that
might be low phosphate or whatever in
bacteria it regulates the activity of a
histidine kinase domain which
autophosphorylates and a histidine and
that very same histidine is then
transferred to the aspartic acid residue
on the receiver domain of a response
regulator which oftentimes acts as a
transcription factor to regulate gene
expression so a very simple signaling
system where you have a a receptor
directly regulating the activity of a
transcription Factor
work identified a sensor histidine
kinase and our work identified a
response regularly so that immediately
suggested that the way that cytokine is
perceived in plant cells is by a two
component signaling pathway now if you
look actually in eukaryotic cells
eukaryotic cells in general don't have a
simple version of the two component
pathway they have a slightly more
complicated version called the
phosphorelay which is very similar
except you add on a pair of extra
phosphoto transfers it still alternates
between a histidine and an aspartic acid
and in general there's a small shuttle
phosphor shuttle protein called a HPT or
histidine fossil transfer protein and
this is the way that cytokine and
signaling works there's a receptor
that's a hybrid sensor kinase that
transfers ultimately a phosphate to a HP
which then results in the
phosphorylation of a of an AR protein
okay so this was sort of immediately
apparent from those two lines of
Investigation
we focused in the beginning on these
aars turns out that these ARS these
response Regulators are a fairly large
Gene family in arabid officers than
other plants
they fall into two very clear Clays two
very distinct claves and we very uh
creatively call them the type A and type
e claims
they are different both in terms of
their sequence similarity the difference
in terms of their domain structure the
type B's consist of both a receiver
domain and a well-defined output domain
that acts as a DNA binding uh element so
this domain binds DNA and has a has an
activation domain so this is a DNA
binding transcription factor in contrast
the type A is really just comprised of
the receiver domain with very in general
very short C terminal domains
and then finally the other difference is
that the taibes are strongly induced by
cytokine and I show you the northern
blot before the particular one I showed
you is that ar5 but most of them are
induced as I'll show you in a second by
cytokinin and the type B's are not
transcriptionally induced by cytokine
but are activated by phosphorylation
okay now the final difference is is once
we identify these and look in the genome
the question is what exactly did they do
and to make a long story short we
basically knocked out all these elements
and asked what effect it had on
exogenous cytokine so on the top there's
just seedlings wild type seedlings
treated with cytokinin the most the
easiest thing to quantify is root
elongation shown on the bottom is you
give higher concentrations of cytokine
in the root growth is inhibited we
quantify that for the type a loss of
functions this is a quadruple mutant
compared to Wild type grown on
increasing concentrations of the
cytokine in ba and we're just measuring
root elongation or actually I guess this
time we're measuring lateral Roots which
is just another measure of cytokine in
response and you can see a
hypersensitivity to cytokine
so that implies loss of function
mutations as these elements increase the
sensitivity of cytokinase so these are
are negative Regulators of the cytokine
pathway
they are very largely functionally
overlapping none of the single mutants
really had much of a phenotype at all
compared to the higher order mutants and
if you would knock out more and more and
more of these you become more and more
and more hypersensitive to cytokine so
these are
at the the 10 000 foot level
functionally overlapping negative
Regulators feedback negative Regulators
of cytokine and sigma
and then this uh the other clay those
type B Clays that again had a DNA
binding domain they had the opposite
phenotype so here's the triple loss of
function here's here's a wild type plant
being sensitive to cytokinin and a
triple type B loss of function that
shows resistant to phytokine so in
addition to all the other differences
between those two clades the type A's or
negative regulators and the type B's are
positive elements in in cytokine in the
sigma
okay so again to make a long story short
work from our lab and other labs have
elucidated really the the canonical
basic cytokine and signaling pathway
which I'll I'll summarize here
The receptors they're called the HKS
they're sensor histidine kinases they're
residing primarily in the endoplasmic
reticulum although there is some
debate in the field that perhaps some of
the receptors are at the plasma membrane
and that may be functionally important
but
minimally I can say that the vast
majority of the receptors are at the
endoplasmic reticulum which by the way
is the same place where the ethylene
receptors are
cytokine binds to a conserved domain
called the chase domain which is either
in the ER Lumen or extracellularly
depending on what you believe binding of
the cytokine and then initiates
uh the fast Auto phosphorylation of the
histidium and histidine kinase domain
the phosphate then is transferred
intramolecularly to a fuse receiver
domain to the ahks phosphate then moves
to these phosphor shuttle proteins
called the ahps which constantly move in
and out of the nucleus in the nucleus
they phosphorylate the type bees again I
should emphasize this is the very same
these are not kinases it's the same
phosphate moving from start to finish
phosphorylation of the type B's then
induce their ability to bind DNA they
bind the DNA and turn on all the genes
that are involved in the response to
cytokinin one set of those genes in the
very early response genes are in fact
the type A aars that I showed you about
showed you before
those themselves are also phosphorylated
by the ahps and their role at least
partially is to negatively regulate the
pathway so they act as they say feedback
negative regulators and we think they
also as I'll tell you in a little bit
probably also interact with other uh
other proteins in a phosphor dependent
manner
and then in addition there's other
players so there's this is a multi-gene
family in arabidopsis and then rice as
I'll talk about in a second there's
other more minor players uh there's a
pseudo HP is that that negative regulate
the fossil transfers and the HPS there's
E3 ligases that result in the turnover
of of the type B's and there's probably
other elements as well that we don't
know about
okay so this is sort of the known
canonical pathway for cytokine and
signaling so I want to go in a little
more depth today about these type aars
and and some thoughts about about what
they do and and and uh how they work and
so it turns out that these are highly
regulated both at the level of
transcription so I kind of showed you
this for ar5 but most of them are
actually transcriptionally induced by
cytokine and most of the induction is
fairly rapid so we're looking at 10
minutes many of these genes are
upregulated in response so they regulate
the level of transcription which we've
known
their transcription is also regulated by
many other different things so for
example this is this is actually from
from uh rice but it doesn't matter this
is just a again nobody does this anymore
but it's called Nano strings where
you're measuring the relative expression
or transcript level of different
proteins uh the line here is that it's
not induced in the control versus the
aux Center ABA this is twofold the
dotted line and anything outside that
dotted line probably means a
significantly upregulated or down
regulated in response to the thing so
the point of this is that if you look at
all the type A's and type B's are on
here as well some of the type A's are
induced for example by bioxin other type
A's are induced by ABA so gets to this
question of why a large Gene family why
are there 10 and it'll see in a little
while there's also uh there's 11 in rice
and the expansion of these families
happen independently in the monocots and
dicots why why are there so many and one
answer to that might well be
that different elements or different
members of the of the gene family
respond to different outputs so one
might be aux inducible one's Ada
inducible and this oxide induction is
really important for example there's
some beautiful work uh that that the
oxygen induction of a type A plays a
role in in the the formation of of a
vasculature foreign
cues so for example high salt strongly
induces air four and six and shoots
pathogens induce it cold induces
different elements so all these
different genes are induced by different
things and and suggests that one of the
reasons this Gene family expanded was to
provide a difference or provide
different inputs from or different
Integrations of different external and
internal signals
okay so in addition to be regulated
transcriptionally these genes were also
regulated post-transcriptionally this is
work from a grad student of mine quite
actually quite some time ago but it will
be relevant in a second so basically
this is in the uh after edition of
cyclohexamine we're looking at the
turnover of these proteins uh in the
presence and absence of cytokinin so the
the dark line is the absence and the
dotted line is the presence of cytokine
and you can see that the top three are
strongly up regulated or strongly
stabilized in response to cytokine in
relative to the absence of cytokinin
others not so much but but but certainly
a subset are highly stabilized by
cytokinin this stabilization we looked
at carefully in the case of ar5 is a
result of the phosphorylation remember I
told you that the pipes are
phosphorylated by the ahps in response
to cytokinin if we look at again here's
the wild type and the presence and
absence of cytokine we're looking at ar5
if you mutate the
fossil acceptor aspartic acid such that
it no longer can be phosphorylated to an
alanine residue you completely lose the
stabilization and response to cytokinin
which strongly suggests that
phosphorylation in response to cytokine
is required for that stabilization and
conversely if you make a fossil mimic
where you change that aspartic acid to
the glutamic acid which
well mimics the the phosphorylation you
get a stabilization
so these proteins in addition to being
transcriptionally regulated are post
transcriptionally regulated at least
through the level of phosphorylation
now in addition to that level of
phosphorylation we also more recently
have looked at the role of autophagy in
regulating type a function and most of
you are probably familiar with autophagy
it's basically a cellular recycling
system where under conditions of
nutrient or carbon stress the plant
breaks down or the organism cells break
down uh various components to reuse the
the parts basically to say it simply and
it involves the uptake of of components
in the degradation in a in a vast in the
uh in the vacuole yeah so so we asked
the question uh whether or not type A
proteins are also regulated by autophagy
and there's there was reasons we did
this and part of it was that many of the
things involved in cytokine overlap with
what happens in autophagy and probably
the best example is is senescence where
senescence involves autophagy and
cytokine has been shown to regulate
senescence
okay so one way to do that is with a a
chemical called concave which basically
blocks the autophag degradation of
proteins and so we looked and asked if
we had concave do we actually stabilize
the proteins then in fact you do so this
is ar4 one of the type A's that that if
you remember go back right quick uh this
was ar-4 which actually was destabilized
by cytokine
it certainly wasn't stabilized it might
in fact be destabilized in response to
cytokinin so ar4 is highly stabilized
when you add concave and inhibit uh
autophagy suggesting that it in the
normal course of events it may be turned
over by autophagy and indeed if you look
at an autophagic mutant atg 5 lacks
autophagy you see an increase in the
western blot by the way for AF air for
gfp you can see that in when you lose
endogenous autophagy you upregulate type
a or function at least this case ar4
okay that's all well good does it really
go into autophagic vesicles and the way
to do that is to add concave and see if
you can see it in vesicles and indeed
you do
so this is again that ar-4 gfp this is a
control when you add conch a you see the
appearance of all these small vesicles I
won't catch all the data but but they
co-localize with autophagic vesicle
markers and that
co-localization disappears in a mutant
that doesn't make autophagic vesicles
atg5
so it tells us that the type A is at
least the subset of the type A's go into
autophagic vesicles and their turnover
is regulated by autophagy in addition to
the regulation by uh
what I showed you previously which I
didn't mention is is 26s proteosome
degradation
now if you remember last time that I
told you about ar5 it seemed like the
phosphorylated form was stabilized here
it's the opposite here the
phosphorylated form is traffic more
frequently to the autophagic vesicles
than the wild type and even which is
traffic more than the D-Day version
again phosphomimic
someone that can't get phosphorylated so
here phosphorylation appears to play the
opposite role that it did what I showed
you previously which again I forgot to
mention but was it 26s proteosome
degradation
so this leads to this this sort of
complex model
where the type A's again are induced in
response to cytokin they're
transcriptionally induced but the
unphosphorylated type A's appear to be
degraded by the 26s produce home in
response to phosphorylation you
stabilize a subset of the type aars
but that phosphorylated type A or is
then becomes targeted by degradation by
the uh by the uh
autophagy and I didn't show you the data
for this but we found that exos 70 is a
receptor that targets the type A's to
the uh autophagiosomes so this is a
shows that there's a complex interplay
between the regulation of the proteins
both when they're phosphorylated and not
phosphorylated suggesting that that the
level of type A proteins is absolutely
critical to proper uh plant growth and
development
now I'm going to come back to the type
A's when I get to the end of this and
I'll show you why but this will sort of
answer the other question of exactly how
do they negatively regulate cytokine and
signaling so so the other thing that
we've done uh relatively recently was
we've tried to find additional elements
that are involved in cytokine and
signaling and at heart really I guess
what I am and what I really love is
genetics and so we designed a genetic
screen to try to search for such
elements yeah
and that screen was the was to find
things that enhanced a mutation that is
disrupted in critical cytokine and
signaling elements but not disrupted
enough to have a phenotypic effect so we
started with the mutant again this is
just a re-elongation assay an increasing
concentrations of cytokinin there are
four functional ahps these are the
phosphor shuttle proteins in the middle
there's four functional ahps if you not
got one or two of those you see very
little effect in in this particular dose
dose response assay
however if you're not got a third one
all of a sudden you become insensitive
or partially insensitive to cytokin so
this is what we would call a sensitized
genetic background where this mutant is
decreased in its ability to transduce a
cytokine signaling but not enough that
we can see a phenotype and the idea
would be if we could find a weak
mutation that might enhance this
phenotype that we might not have found
through this screening a wild type plant
so it's screening for an enhanced uh an
enhancer screen basically and we use
this concentration here which we thought
was a nice signal to noise ratio in
terms of of looking at it
so we identified a lot of these we
identified after re-screening and
everything about 150 independent uh what
we call e e a h uh mutants enhancers of
ahps after we remove the ions one of the
things you find very frequently in these
screens are ethylene and sensitive
mutants because the reason that the root
gets shorter is because cytokine induces
ethylene biosynthesis which inhibits
root elongation so we found a lot of
ions we got rid of those and we're
really focused on on things that were
not ethylene insensitive
but we got 150 lines that's a lot of
lines and what do you do typically what
a geneticist would do would they pick
their four or five favorite lines and
clone them uh and figure out who's
dominant who's recessive and find out
how many complementation groups but but
we were I guess lazy
uh and we decided rather than just pick
our few favorite lines let's take all
150 lines and move them forward and try
to identify the causative mutations of
all 150 ahp lines
and I don't have time to tell you about
this today I'd be happy to talk
afterwards if somebody's interested but
we use the uh
technique that we now dub metagenomics
where we sequenced all 150 lines and put
it through a particular pipeline that
helped us to identify the causative
mutations in many of those lines not all
of them but many of them
so the first part of our pipeline the
first thing that comes out are genes
that we knew would be involved in the
process and the one that we thought and
in fact turned out to be so would be the
most common mutation is the cytokine
receptor ahk4 why because it's the
largest the largest Gene the coding
regions around 3000 bases the whole Gene
somewhere is around five or six KB but
also it's the prompt predominant
cytokine receptor in Roots and
loss of function mutations at ahk4 give
you remarkably long routes compared to
the wild type nearly completely
insensitive so we're not surprised to
find lots of alleles of hk4 and in one
sense we can almost use this as sort of
a a mini structure function study and
some of the things that we found that
were interesting we actually mutated the
aspartic acid residue that is the target
of phosphorylation we found two
independent uh missense mutations where
we change that to an asparagine residue
we found lots of mutations other
mutations in the receiver domain the
ones in Gray by the way are just
nonsense or splice mutations so not
informative in the sense of structure
function
uh the other thing we found a lot of
that was a little surprising we found a
lot of mutations here in the early
transmembrane domain before the chase
them and the things that we knew they
were functional we knew that the chase
domain bound cytokinin we knew the
histidine kinase initiated the phosphoto
transfer and we knew the receiver domain
accepted a phospho transfer from the
histidine residue in the ahk so we
didn't really find much in the history
being kinase that made but we found a
four actually five mutations that
affected this first transmembrane domain
perhaps suggesting that the protein
doesn't traffic correctly or in some way
shape or form uh cause protein
dysfunction
and then the last thing that was
interesting is you'll see the 2x here
means that we found three independent
mutations twice
same exact mutation two times meaning
that this screen is remarkable
remarkable the screen is saturated
because we're finding the same
nucleotide changes in independent lines
we know they're independent lines
because we sequence The genome and the
only mutation that these two lines share
they're from independent pool so one
would expect them to be independent but
the only mutation that they shared was
that was the causative mutation the
other 150 mutations floating around the
line were not shared in common between
those lines so we found the same hits
three separate times independently
okay so that's that's you know not all
that great as we expected it but but
that's not too surprising we also find
other things that we knew like the other
HK receptor we found in some alleles out
we found a type B a r we found ox1 which
is known to be ethylene insensitive in
Roots and so I would have anticipated
that we found acs7 which they didn't
really expect but but
but told us that that this particular
ACC synthase is a target of uh cytokine
and root elongation uh which is
different than the Target that we found
in darkroom ceiling I think anybody's
interested I can tell you about that one
as well so those were the knowns but
then what the question is what were the
unknowns no unknown unknowns what is a
Cheney said anyway uh what were the
other the novel things that we found so
I won't go through all of them but the
one of the novel ones that we found that
was particularly interesting was an
allele of high five and this is sort of
illustrates to you the utility of the
screen so here's that two three mutant
that we started with that we mutagenized
it looks pretty much exactly like wild
type and if you add another HP loss of
function you get a longer root here's a
high five tdna by itself it gives you a
weak ethylene cytokine and insensitivity
but in the background of the two three
which is what these two line which is
what this line is you get substantial
cytokine and insensitivity which is
exactly what we were screening we're
trying to find things that that we
probably wouldn't have found this is a
mutant but this would be pretty easy to
Screen through and find so that
illustrates the utility of the enhancer
screen
okay so what is high five high five is a
transcription factor that integrates
many different uh signaling inputs it
plays certainly was it first identified
as a role in light uh responsive gene
expression and morphogenesis but it's
been linked to many other plant hormones
so Downstream of of high five ABA oxen
GA breast and asteroid and ethylene have
all been linked Downstream Upstream of
high fives cytokine via cops but
ethylene and GA and strigalactones they
both have been linked so it's an
integrated integrator of many different
hormone signals so the question is how
much of a role did it really play in
cytokine and signal so we did two things
we did Chip analysis where we tried to
ask the genes what are the genes that
are targeted by high five in the genome
and how do they compare to the genes
that were targeted by type B's and we
found a remarkable overlap of almost 60
percent of the genes
that were targeted by high five were
also targeted by type B ARS what that
says is that they have a large overlap
in their target genes that these two
transcription factors hit
likewise of course that's true one would
expect that there would be changes in
gene expression or high five would
affect gene expression and here what
we're looking at is genes that are
induced by cytokine in a wild type plant
and genes that are induced by cytokine
and then high five you can see again
many of the genes overlap but there's
252 genes that are no longer induced by
cytokine and then high five and then
another 500 or so genes that are now
transcriptionally induced by cytokine in
in the high five mutant that aren't
transcriptionally induced in the wild
type so it seems like Hi-Fi plays an
important role in mediating the
transcriptional response to cytokine
and I wanna
go from this to sort of a bigger idea
without a whole lot of data but I'll
I'll just give you our hypothesis and
where we're going with this so one of
the questions I started with is how does
one molecule do so many different things
and then secondly what is out of the
type A's negatively regulate cytokine
and signaling so one of the answers in
mammalian cells and other systems is how
a single molecule can do so many
different things is the presence of
partner transcription factors it defines
what is called context-dependent
signaling that there's a primary target
of a signaling pathway in our case it's
the type B ARS
and the Suites of genes that are
regulated by the type DARS is determined
by their interaction with a series of
other partnered transcription factors
and all those transcription factors
shown on the left have been identified
as factors that directly interact with
type Bars by our lab and other labs as
well the one I just showed you is high
five but we identified crfs and bpcs and
in3s dollars have been shown to interact
with type B's all those elements on the
left or transcription factors have been
shown to interact with type bar so our
hypothesis
is that it's a combination of cytokine
and signaling with the partner
transcription factors that determines
the precise output of the cytokine and
signaling pathway in a particular cell
or tissue type and that it's the
combination of these two that then
determine their uh the function of
cytokine in that particular cell type so
that is one hypothesis that we're
currently addressing for how cytokine
can do so many other things other
possibilities include the fact that
there's multiple type B's and multiple
HKS and then the role of Chromatin is
probably important as well but this we
think plays a role as well
but the other thing this this got us to
is this idea of again we knew early on
that the type A's played a role as a
negative regulator of cytokines signal
but we didn't and we still don't really
know the mechanism so one simple idea
was that the type A is just
heterodimerized with the type B's
which is how oxen the ox IAS and the
Arps work that would be a simple idea
and that this finest functionally binds
DNA and this doesn't and the heterodimer
wouldn't bind that doesn't seem to be
the case we and many other people have
looked for interaction of the type A's
and the type B's and have not found any
a second possibility that they just
compete for phospho flow from the ahps
but we've also ruled that out as a sole
mechanism because we know that the
phospho mimics of the type base which
can't be phosphorylated
still are functional
so then what then how do they work and
one idea how they work and I will stress
this is at this point mostly a
hypothesis is that they compete for
binding to these partner transcription
factors what do we know so far we know
that the types interact with it with the
transcription factors shown here and we
know that the type A is also we did a
large screen exhaustive to hybrid screen
with a set of playbase and Thomas
schmulling had done a screen another a
set of kind of researcher in Germany did
a screen for the type pers and we found
a series of overlapping transcription
factors that interacted with both
and so we're testing the hypothesis now
that the way that the taibes ACT is by
competing for for interaction with these
partner transcription factors but again
I want to stress it's just like
hypothesis we don't actually have the
answers yet
okay
so this is sort of a summary of the work
with type A so I first showed told you
that the types are redundant partially
redundant negative regulators and they
act as feedback inhibitors for the
cytokine pathway
they're regulated at multiple levels
transcription protein stability and by
phosphorylation they're also regulated
by both exogenous and endogenous signals
uh they act to probably integrate
multiple different signals uh to
modulate the cytokine sensitivity of a
particular cell or a particular tissue
and then finally they may act by
competing with type B's for partner
transcription factors so that's sort of
where we're at with the type A's
and what how long do I hatch again I've
been paying attention well we still have
10 minutes just 10 minutes yeah that's
not a lot okay uh well I'm going to tell
you quickly about our work on Rice then
so so almost all the functions of
cytokinin were delineated in the dicot
arabidopsis right and we were interested
in moving into a monocot and we chose
rice for a couple reasons one reason is
that rice is uh
they wrote on here anyway rice accounts
for about 23 of all the calories
consumed by humans on Earth the amount
of rice made or harvested worldwide has
been increasing in the last 60 years or
so but it is beginning at least in China
to to uh to uh Plateau out so there's
not combined with global climate change
and increasing climate means that we
need to make more rice to feed the world
and so I don't go through this but but
climate change has a very strong
negative impact on on Rice yield so
there needs to be ways to increase rice
yield to keep up with the increasing
human population so rice in particular
plays an important role in yield in in
cereals in general uh there's some
beautiful work
um from matsuoka's Lab in Nagoya where
he showed that that there's two main
varieties of rice Brown in the world
japonic and indica the Indica being a
higher yielding variety they cross those
two together they identified a single
qtl that accounted for about 80 percent
of the yield difference
uh that qtl was a loss of function of a
gene called cytokine and oxidase which
is a gene that degrades cytokinin uh and
results in the high yielding variety
have a high having a higher level of
cytokine in during the early panicle
development
presumably increasing cell division in
the formation of spikelets and yield
so we think cytokine can play an
important role if manipulated
appropriately to increase both rice
yield and perhaps other cereals as well
so this is a cytokine and signaling
pathway in rice it looks just like a
rabbit opposite is just slightly
different names so our approach was to
knock out using Crispers the different
cytokine analysis so we've knocked out
all four receptors both HPS the three
phps and all 10 or 13 type A's uh and as
well as a collaborator is knocked out
the type B is and asked what happens to
Rice growth and development
so I'll tell you first the work we've
done with it with ahks so if you look at
the the phylogeny of the arabidopsis
rice age caves they inter-digitate
nicely you can see clear orthologous
relationships suggesting that the
progenitor of monocots and dicots
probably had uh three genes three
receptor genes
if you knock these genes out you see an
increasing severity of phenotypes from
the singles we have all of them but I
don't have a pictures for all of them
but it holds up with others you from the
singles to the the higher order mutants
culminating with the quadruple mutant
which basically doesn't make a shoot at
all and makes it best in abbreviated
route
and I go through this in turn shoot same
thing increase the the loss of function
HKS you end up with a tiny little shoot
uh if you knock them all out you end up
with no shoot but you knock out three of
the five or three of the four you get an
abbreviated shoot I'm gonna run out of
time so I'm gonna go through this pretty
quick they flower much later than their
wild type counterparts if you knock
enough of them out
um and there there wasn't a whole lot of
indication that cytokine and regulated
flowering time in arabidopsis but it
plays an important role in rice it seems
like trichome formation is defective in
the higher order of mutants these are
the rice trichomes this is the surface
of a leaf those are the trichomes in a
wild type or they're nearly absent in
the higher order mutants and we quantify
that
uh the number of tillers is
substantially reduced to the higher
order mutant important agronomic trait
uh relative to the wild type again this
is just tillers over time wild type this
lower order beats don't have a strong
phenotype but some of the combinations
have a strong phenotype particularly the
three four five
the angle of the tillers seems to be
different this is a wild type plant you
can see that the tillers are coming out
at maybe uh the uh whatever that angle
is but you can see that 345 is a much
more upright plant and again tiller
angle is a really important trait for
rice in the field
but the most so some of those things are
very different than what we found in
rabbit Ops is some are the same
but the most dramatic difference came
comes here with the quadruple loss of
receptor function so here this is a
triple loss of function with three of
the four receptors are not doubt two
four six this is a quadruple mutant and
these plants are actually two weeks
older than these plants this is about as
big as they ever get sometimes they
never make a root or shoot sometimes
they make a little tiny abbreviated root
but they never make a shoot at all
now if this is the plant that I started
with I would have said of course they're
not going to make a shoot I told you way
back when in the 50s scuga Miller showed
that cytokine is essential to form
shoots
and this then would be the culmination
of that work however if you look at so
this is just a close-up of it it never
makes a shoot very unhappy little guy if
you look at rabidopsis and we've done
that we've actually made triple nominees
where we know that they're nulls they
make absolutely no functional protein
those plants still make a shoot now
albeit the shoot is smaller they still
have trichomes they still make a shoot
and they make a reduced route but they
do have a shoot it still makes several
set sleeves so it's a very different
situation between rice and arabidopsis
and if you want to extrapolate that to
monocots and dicots in the case of rice
cytokine is essential for shoot
formation in the case of a rapidopsis
it's not and one of the reasons that
it's probably essential in rice is that
if you look at the size in this case the
inflorescence meristem in a double
mutant is greatly reduced in size and
what we're currently doing is we're
trying to section through early embryo
development and see if that should
apical maristamp disappears in the in
the HK quadruple mutant
okay I'm gonna run out of time so I want
to get to the type A's but that affects
Spike or the formation of the
inflorescence as you knock out the type
A is the inflorescence gets really
smaller you're not falling out you get
no shoot in fact flower development
stigmatic brushes again this is not a
phenotype you see in arabidopsis even
the triple receptor mutants
when they do flower you don't really see
effects on floral formation
size which you do see in arabidopsis but
the single loss of functions for the HKS
have bigger seeds than the wild type
uh and the roots are strikingly affected
part partially the result of very stem
size okay in the last couple minutes let
me tell you about so that's that's the
age case so the HK is again as in
arabidopsis seemed to be fairly
pleiotropic they affect root development
ceiling development
uh shoot development inflorescence and
floral development
so the thing we've done most recently is
we've been started to work on the type
aars which are a large Gene family and
we split them into four independent
clades and knocked out each clade in
turn one of the things I want you to get
from this is this is very different from
the phylogeny I showed you with ahk the
HK is the HKS from rice in the
rapidopsis more or less interdigitated
here the arabidopsis and rice
type A's played completely separately
suggesting that these two Gene families
uh
expanded independently in monocots the
die-cuts are after the monocot and dicot
split which might be the fact that these
things are induced by different uh
environmental endogenous signals I
talked about before so what are the
phenotypes of the type A's this is
really just starting but but one of the
interesting phenotypes we see very
clearly in this particular clade here
this quintuple clade right here where we
knock out all five of these genes we see
the twinning of the embryos we see about
no no no 70 of the embryos are either
Twins or even sometimes three uh we see
other aberrations in the shoot as well
but the most common thing we see is
twinning
and we're trying to figure out why that
is again in contrast to the ahks we see
more trichomes relative to the wild type
uh you Quantified that here so there's
more trichomes the opposite phenotype of
what you'd expect from the HKS which HKS
are insensitive these are hypersensitive
so you'd expect more trichomes if you
look at the inflorescence one of the
slides I showed you when I started my
the the rice discussion was that loss a
function of a cytokine and oxidase which
degrades cytokine and had a bitter
bigger panicle so one anticipation might
be if you knock out the right
combination of type A's you may increase
panicle size and in this particular
quintuple indeed you do you have more
spikelets and you have more secondary
branches than you do in the wild type
um so again we're in early days but but
I think different combinations might
might even give us a more dramatic
effect uh maybe something approaching
what we see with uh with the Indica
Japonica varieties
okay so just to summarize our rice work
and sorry I went through that pretty
quick but but uh the basic idea is that
what we found is that the Aged case
redundantly regulates cytokine
insensitivity rights just like they do
in arabidopsis
and the four HKS played distinct but
overlapping roles in many different
aspects of development
some of those some of the roles that we
see in rice are similar to what's in
rabbits as an example elongation uh but
some are very more prominent in rice so
there is sort of some indication that
trichomes might be affected by cytokine
in arabidopsis but they're absolutely
affected in rice and some are really
pretty much unique the first of all the
complete lack of a shoot in a quadruple
and and some other phenotypes that we
see have no comparators to to the
arabidopsis and and most interestingly
as I said knocking out all four of them
results in a completely shoeless
phenotype which is very different than
what we've seen in rabbitopsis and
finally the type A's uh also negatively
regulates cytokine and signaling and
rice just like they do in arabidopsis
and they also affect multiple aspects of
development in a uh functionally
overlapping way and some of the things
that we've looked at I've shown you some
I haven't shown you but it includes
tiller number chlorophyll content Leaf
development panicle architecture
trichome density and Seed size as well
as other phenotypes as well so we're
really kind of early days in in
quantifying the um the uh developmental
effects of these so really uh that's
where we're at now what we really are
going to try to do is we're going to now
go back into where am I here into our
current work if I get to this we're
going to go back to these inflorescences
uh both the vegetative and the
inflorescent smart stem and do like
everybody else on Earth the Single Cell
to try to find out first of all in a
rice panicle uh timing the the
kinds of cell types and the the
developmental projectories but then also
try to figure out how cytokine Alters
that
and then we're going to continue to
characterize these mutants and identify
the different phenotypes so that's where
lln and I'll just tell you the folks
that did the work uh Eva is a I've been
in the lab for about a year or so she's
a great uh uh graduate student Emily uh
actually was an undergraduate my lab
went to Michigan State and has come back
as a postdoc uh and then these are some
undergraduates that have worked in the
lab and some of the folks that started
the rice work in my lab include
Christian uh and and Kevin had done that
um I'm sorry Asha and then these are our
collaborators we collaborated with Eric
for a long time and instead of kind of
jiggling Josh stable who's in my Scanlon
lab is doing the shoot apical meristem
single cell with us and some of the
other folks have been collaborating with
us they're showing up here as well so
I'll stop there and be happy to take any
questions you might have
yeah
so the Taipei mutants and rice that I've
been to today also have a larger cell
and it's the contact I don't know yeah
to be honest with you we literally just
started doing those sections about two
weeks ago uh I don't know the answer
um the the hairy sheath mutant in Maize
which is a gain of function mutant in uh
a cytokine receptor according to Josh
anyway it's not published according to
Josh that also showed twinning in in
maze
because it's a single mutation with type
A yeah AB for one yeah yeah
but I don't think it's a twinning did it
the Advil one
is so large yeah yeah so I don't we're
looking at the barrier some size right
now but I don't I assume that they do
but I don't know the answer to that yet
but yeah it's a good question
yeah
so I really like this transcription
Factor model was the response Regulators
interacting with this group
of TFS because it kind of helps yeah it
helps understand how everything's doing
everything but so I'm curious what you
know are they how complicated do you
think that is in terms of are these all
two molecule reactions or if you think
they're more complex than that and the I
guess the rest of the question is
those were things that you showed you
had interactions yeah yeah
direct physical
of course it still works yeah yeah and
there's probably a lot of other TFS you
could infer should fit into that group
so I'm just kind of wondering what are
you yeah I mean you're thinking exactly
the same way we're thinking in exactly
the same direction I'm guessing it's
going to be remarkably complicated at a
single cell level maybe not so much
maybe at a single cell level there'll be
a suite of partner transcription factors
that interact with the type B's under
particular conditions and as you say it
could be it could be that they directly
interact with the type E's it could be
that they're part of a large complex or
it could be that they independently hit
independent CIS acting elements and just
co-regulate in that way and that's the
way it works in animal cells
um so I mean we're very early days but
those are those are the exact so one of
the first things I want to do is I want
to uh take a reporter line with
particular targets for type ease and
then just dial up and down type a
function and see if this hypothesis is
right because at this point it's just a
hypothesis really but it's got to be
something like that because the
specificity it does so many different
things it has to be partner
transcription factors and I can't find a
particular other mechanism by which type
A's negative regulate the pathway I
think it would nicely solve both those
problems or at least stress both those
questions but but but it's early days
and my guess is it's going to be both
both both what everything you said was
probably going to be true it's probably
simple uh heterodimers with the type B's
and the partners is probably going to be
large protein complexes and I also think
there's probably going to be independent
targeting of uh CIS acting elements as
well
but that's where we're heading so our
next branch
yeah
concerning the spatial regulations
I mean you did talk about that
transcription Factor um
um I wonder because you also shot those
five different mutants in the age of ah
phase yeah are there or how many
homologs do you usually have a age case
within one genome basically and do you
see if there's different mutations in
those homologs and there's different
busy different age cases different
alleles expressed in different they talk
about different plant species is that
what you mean
if I look across the phylogeny of plants
do you see different age caves in
different places is that what you're
asking um more than one genome let's say
you have
I don't know 10 copies of a 10 different
ah keys that have mutations and are thus
expressed in different tissue types and
then have different Downstream effects
yeah I mean that's certainly part of
understanding how one signal does
different things is you have multiple
receptors and multiple ahps and multiple
type B's right so the combinatorial
diversity of of in the case of of a
rabbit houses it's three HKS
or functional HPS and I remember right
11 type B's and you do the math that's a
pretty large number of different
combinatorial uh outputs I think that's
part of it I do think that's part of
what in part specificity but we also
know that there's a huge amount of
functional overlap so the type A is
you know if we knock out
single type base we see almost no
phenotype and there's actually
relatively oddly enough relatively
little information gained by patterns of
expression and who's functioning
overlapping with who and I
would have anticipated there would have
been but it doesn't seem to be that's
true for the ipts as well the bio
synthetic enzymes
um part of that answer might be that if
you knock out a suite of type A's you
get compensatory upregulation of some
other type A's you know what I mean so
so I'm not quite sure I'm answering your
question but but certainly we do think
that that tissue specific expression of
different components within the pathway
contributes to uh a specificity of
function I think that's certainly true
but that's that's only a small part of
the answer it has to be something else
as well I'm not sure to answer your
question or not but we could chat later
if you want but but yeah
other questions so there's a question
for online oh yeah how do we do that
yeah I don't know I'm still stuck in the
first slide here
I don't know why that's different from
that yeah I don't know what's going on
there I'm interested
well I don't know
why oh no okay no don't worry about it
again oh okay
what do I do now
oh there we go all right
yes yes yeah so actually for for several
of the type A if you haven't actually
done this for the type ease a lot the
interaction definitely depends on
phosphorylation if we look at the fossil
mimic versus the wild type we see much
stronger interaction with the phosphoid
mimic than we do for the wild type but
that's only true for a subset of the uh
of the transcription factors and we
haven't actually explored that that much
with the type beats but yeah that's a
great question and that's absolutely
true that there is some of that
um speaker audio is not working huh too
late now uh anyway so that's a great
question Yeah we actually definitely see
phosphodependent interactions
okay any other questions
yeah
for a while well first of all thank you
for a wonderful
um you know I'm sort of struck the the
fact that the receptors for citibility
and ethylene they are located in the art
yeah and it's always about me why ER
okay my grandmother used to say that's
the way God made it uh the case of for
the case of ethylene it probably is fine
right because ethylene is really really
permeable to the membrane and actually
ethylene binds within the membrane to
the receptor so it's not surprising that
it would be an internal membrane for for
for ethylene the cytokine ones I don't
honestly have a good answer for you
um
I I would the first papers that came out
for cytokine and showed showed that it
was in the plasma membrane which is
where everybody expected it to be but
but if you look at the high Affinity
cytokine but the best work on this has
been done by Thomas schmulling for a
localized both gfp fusions but he also
looked at in a wild type plan High
Affinity cytokine in binding and
saturable hyphenated study kind of
binding in almost all associated with
the ER
so I think it's clear that's where it is
I think there might be a small I mean
it's hard to argue that a small fraction
of it doesn't go to the plasma membrane
and and that part's functional I can't
rule that out but certainly the majority
of the ahks are at the plasma at the ER
why that should be I honestly don't have
a good answer for you bugs me too but
but I don't I don't know why I mean
maybe maybe because there's cross block
with the ethylene receptors and that's
where the ethylene receptors are that
might be the most
simple answer but I don't really know if
that's true or not but I don't know yeah
uh in that realm I'm wondering how the
theater kind of
games
how does it get in and how does it get
into the Lumen of the ER because it has
to bind in the Lumen of the ER so
there's been
multiple potential Transporters
identified like a pop Transporters which
are purine Transporters have been shown
to transport cytokinin uh hitoshi
sakakibar has shown some really nice
work about some Transporters that export
cytokinem into the xylem stream but as
far as I know we don't know the cytokine
transporter that brings it certainly
into the Lumen of the ER and that was
one of the things I anticipated maybe
finding in our screen that maybe would
have found some Transporters also uh
what's his name
anyway so there's a bunch of papers out
there about different potential
cytokinase receptors I don't think any
of them as far as I know are in the ER
and I don't know that there's a Smoking
Gun to prove that any of them actually
bring it into the plant cell at the
moment but there's a bunch of
possibilities but yes it's a great
question one that bothers me is both
those questions bother me
yeah I'm not sure how the experiments
were done
in the ER yeah but
um
was the fact that there's so much more
ER membrane than plasma membrane
um taken into consideration when saying
well I didn't do them but the two
experiments that were done were they
localized fluorescent proteins and and
the flushing protein is effectively
99 of it localized to the ER and
effectively almost none of it was at the
plasma membrane I mean it's really hard
to say that none of it's there but but
but effectively they saw almost none for
the for the high Affinity binding there
was essentially no satchable high
Affinity binding that they did sucrose
gradients and they saw no high finity
saturnal binding that associated with
the plasma membrane and they said
essentially all of it associated with
the with the ER
by biochemical fractionation of the of
the membranes
okay great um many many thanks for yours
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu